[GUITAR PLAYING]
DAVE: Today we're joined
by singer-songwriter,
multi-instrumentalist, recording
artist, and Grammy winner Rob
Hotchkiss.
Rob's probably best known
for founding the band Train,
who released hits including
"Meet Virginia" and "I Am,"
and their best-known
"Drops of Jupiter,"
which won the Grammy for
Best Rock Song in 2001.
Since 2003, Rob's been
pursuing his solo endeavors
and focusing on songwriting
and raising his family.
And he's recently
returned to the Bay Area
and returned to songwriting.
So today we have a special
performance from him
and his wife Pamela to show
off some of their new songs.
So without any further ado,
please welcome Rob Hotchkiss.
[APPLAUSE]
ROB HOTCHKISS: Good
evening, Cleveland.
PAM HOTCHKISS: I
forgot the set list.
ROB HOTCHKISS: So
here we are at Google.
You guys are like
innovators, right?
We're going to do
an experiment here.
Guitar has a way
to traditionally
be tuned, E, A, D, G, B,
E. You won't hear that.
Every guitar I've got
here is tuned differently.
I have my reasons for that.
Partly I got bored
after a while.
Back in Train, actually
in the beginning,
I would just--you'd write a
song and it just needed to be
a certain way.
And I owned one guitar.
So if you're going
to play shows,
my thought was, well, I
need to write three more
songs in that tuning
so I'm not sitting
there tuning up in front
of people the whole time.
So this is Dadgad, D-A-D-G-A-D.
Just something I felt like I
discovered, but some other
people have tried this one.
But a song from
a record we have.
If you guys want to
grab one when you leave,
called "Midnight Ghost"
that I made a while ago,
a song called "Rainmaker."
Two, three, four.
[MUSIC - ROB HOTCHKISS,
"RAINMAKER"]
[APPLAUSE]
PAM HOTCHKISS: Thank you.
ROB HOTCHKISS: And here's one
of those early Train songs.
This is probably
like-- I think I
wrote "Free," then "Homesick,"
then probably this one,
called "Eggplant."
[MUSIC - ROB HOTCHKISS,
"EGGPLANT"]
[APPLAUSE]
ROB HOTCHKISS: And here's my
interpretation of the open G.
[MUSIC - ROB HOTCHKISS]
[APPLAUSE]
ROB HOTCHKISS: So Jimmy
Page found that tuning too.
Now this one I swear I made up.
So I'm writing a
song, and it just--
string by string I could
tell what I needed to do
to get the sound that I wanted.
And this one's
particularly strange.
This is a 12-string guitar,
so there's more strings to it.
But you know, normally
you'd tune it in Ds and As
or something.
That makes some sense because
then some of the strings
would be the same.
This one needed to be
D sharp and A sharp.
It just did.
Song called "Blind Faith."
Two, three, four.
[MUSIC - ROB HOTCHKISS, "BLIND
FAITH"]
[APPLAUSE]
ROB HOTCHKISS: We
played this song
at TEDx Berkeley, which
is where we met Gopi.
Does anybody here know Gopi?
So he's a Googler.
Google does the--
PAM HOTCHKISS: Marketing.
ROB HOTCHKISS: He's one
of the [? yogler. ?]
He created that thing.
So great guy.
You should meet him.
And he found us at TEDx
and said, come play Google,
and I'm like, yes, my
favorite company on the road.
So not just kissing up.
But I'm a shareholder
too, so we have
to inspire you guys to
keep doing great things.
AUDIENCE: More productivity.
ROB HOTCHKISS: More
productivity, exactly.
And maybe think
outside of the box.
If I'm going to tune my guitar
to D sharps and A sharps,
you guys can at least
figure out some new way
to do something, right?
PAM HOTCHKISS: But
can I make a comment?
When you Google him,
sometimes Pat's face comes up.
So if you can fix,
that would be great.
ROB HOTCHKISS: Yeah,
somebody, please.
Don't have the lead
singer's face come up
when you Google Rob Hotchkiss.
I know Dave's
working on that one,
but we need the whole crew here.
This is a song called
"Gods Laughing."
[MUSIC - ROB HOTCHKISS, "GODS
LAUGHING"]
[APPLAUSE]
ROB HOTCHKISS: Thanks.
So this is proof that
when you write one,
you got to write two or three.
So Dave mentioned I had
left Train and embarked
on a solo career.
The truth is I
actually disappeared
for better part of a decade.
And why am I doing this again?
Because I wrote these songs.
You write songs, are you going
to throw them in your closet
or are you going to put
them in front of people?
So I wrote "Blind
Faith," "Gods Laughing."
"Gods Laughing," by the
way, is a pagan song.
It's the gods.
All those gods are
laughing, not just that one.
This one's called "Glide,"
and the most recent one
that I wrote.
[MUSIC - ROB HOTCHKISS, "GLIDE"]
[APPLAUSE]
ROB HOTCHKISS: Thanks.
PAM HOTCHKISS: Thank you.
And now they're going to do Q&A.
ROB HOTCHKISS: Thanks for
sharing your lunch time
with us.
PAM HOTCHKISS: Yeah,
thanks for coming out.
DAVE: Thank you, Rob.
We're here at Google
with Rob Hotchkiss.
Guys, what do you think
of that performance?
Can we hear it one
more time for Rob?
Rob, thank you so much
for coming and joining us
today, playing for us,
telling your stories.
I guess my first question
would be about what
inspired the new songs.
After being a
musician all your life
and taking a 10-year hiatus,
was this just the first time
in 10 years you sat
down and wrote them,
or the first time
they came to you?
What inspired the new era of
songwriting and new music?
ROB HOTCHKISS: Well,
my disappearing act
had much to do with
learning piano, actually.
I mean, we wrote
"Drops of Jupiter."
That's kind of the first piano
song that Train ever had.
So I played it live.
So I got to do that
for a few years.
And it got me interested in--I
was a little bored with guitar,
I guess.
So for about six
or seven years, I
was learning
Beethoven and Schubert
or whatever, and just really
excited about the instrument,
and kind of put the
guitar down, really.
So about a year and a half ago
I moved back to the Bay Area
to actually play with one of
the former members of Train.
Charlie Colin and
Tom Luce and I put
a band together called
Painbirds, wherein
I picked up my guitar again.
And I think when I picked up
the 12-string, I was recording,
and I just got into this thing
where the tuning kind of tuned
itself to what I was hearing.
And like I said, I
wrote "Blind Faith."
And if you're
going to write one,
you may as well write some more.
So I came up with that
batch of songs that way.
DAVE: Wonderful.
And how has some of the
content of the things that you
write songs about changed now?
I mean, you're a
different man now
than you were when
you were writing,
say, "Drops of Jupiter" and
the original Train songs.
Do you find deeper
meaning in them?
Do you find that you're
writing about different things?
What are you writing
about these days?
ROB HOTCHKISS: I think
my stuff has always
had a bit of-- I don't
want to say message,
because that sounds
dated or whatever.
But I don't want to
just write pop songs.
They have to come from my heart.
"Blind Faith," I think-- that
song, you look out at the world
and you just see
some things that are
going on that are disturbing.
And I thought to myself, what
is it in me that I could see?
You can look out there
and see these things.
What is it about me as a person?
So part of that
song is about you
got this going on out there.
Am I treating the
people around me the way
they deserve to be treated?
So it's kind of saying,
you know, we're humanity,
but we're also-- we
have that all within us.
And let's think about
that and get it together.
DAVE: Thanks.
Now in a bit we're going to
go to audience questions,
if you guys have them.
So if you would like
to ask Rob a question,
please start lining up
at that mic back there.
Before we go to that, I
wonder if you could regale us
with a Train story that maybe
no one knows, maybe something
from time on the road or
from a recording session,
something that sticks
out in your mind
as being one of the
fondest memories.
ROB HOTCHKISS: I don't have
a great, like, funny one,
at least off the
tip of my tongue.
But I mean, we did a song
that nobody ever heard,
which I think is one of
the--the best Train stuff
nobody's heard.
It was the early demos.
But there was one where we did
a song for a Mel Gibson movie,
and we did it in Abbey Road.
So just being in
Studio B, which is
where the Beatles are walking
up the stairs in "Let It Be."
So to be there.
John Landau had just
started managing us.
It was the first time he
had really seen the band.
We wrote the song on the tour
bus on the way to the studio.
It's called "Fallout."
You can find it on-- Google it.
Google it.
Thanks, Pam.
Yeah, Google "Fallout."
Maybe you'll find it.
I don't know.
It was on-- "We Were
Soldiers," I think,
was the Mel Gibson movie.
It was on the soundtrack,
not in the movie.
But there was some magic there.
We had a guy play bagpipes.
We had the female background
singers doing some Pink Floyd
kind of stuff.
Just that moment.
And I had to sit
down on the piano
and play "You Only
Give Me Your Money."
The other guys are like,
hey, it's sacrosanct.
I'm not going to not do
that if I'm sitting here.
DAVE: And how have you
been over your career,
at, like, judging your own work?
Do you know when a
song's going to be a hit?
Does it feel like a hit to you?
Or are there other
songs out there
where you're like, I
can't believe this one
didn't take off.
This is the best
one we've ever made.
ROB HOTCHKISS: I've not
been good at selecting hits.
"Meet Virginia," I couldn't--
people were all kind of like,
really?
I think I'd know when
they're really bad.
You don't hear those, I hope.
Maybe you heard a couple today.
I hope not.
But yeah, knowing
what a hit is, boy, I
would never want to
get into that business.
DAVE: And I think I'll go to
our first audience question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, this is Chris.
Since you spent time
learning the piano,
how has that affected your
guitar playing or composing
or things like that?
ROB HOTCHKISS: Learning
piano may have had something
to do with some of these new
tunings that I'm dabbling with.
On piano, everything's there.
Anything you want
to do, you can do.
I can hit any kind of notes.
Guitar, the way
they've decided to tune
a guitar, standard
tuning, it's most
conducive to being able
do the most things with,
but it just doesn't
sound the best to me.
It doesn't ring.
There's even a theory that
the Nazis had something
to with A 440, that it
was to terrorize the world
or something.
But I'm not going there.
But even take a guitar
and tune it lower.
Do something, you know?
And so maybe just--
I don't know,
bend the rules a little bit.
So piano got me re-excited.
Doing all that piano
got me-- finally
when I got back to guitar, I
was really excited to revisit
an old friend.
I did some composing
on piano as well.
DAVE: Some of the songs you
played for us on guitar today
were originally
composed on piano,
and you had to figure out
how to kind of transpose them
into a guitar arrangement?
ROB HOTCHKISS:
These, not actually.
These were written on guitar.
DAVE: So there's
more in the closet
that we can expect coming soon?
ROB HOTCHKISS: Yeah, perhaps.
DAVE: Looks like we have
someone heading over
for another live question.
AUDIENCE: First
of all, thank you.
I really enjoyed all your songs.
I wanted to ask you, when
you're writing a song,
I know people probably ask you,
how do you know you're done?
But then what is the process
that you go through when
you're creating a song?
I'd love to know what.
ROB HOTCHKISS: I think the
songwriting process for me,
it's almost like a
song will come to me.
The last song that
I played you guys
called "Glide," that guitar
part, the main guitar part
came to me, and part of
the vocal came to me.
And I kept telling
my family, I said,
this is either going to be the
best or the worst song I ever
wrote, because you
have to believe in it.
You know, this
thing comes to you.
It's almost I feel
like a receiver.
If you just put
yourself in the place
where something can come to you.
It helps to have a
guitar in your hand,
or you sing at the piano.
But it comes to you, and then
you just have to believe in it.
You know, it's more typical for
me that I end up with the thing
that I started with
than that I jettison it.
And there are
exceptions, but it's
kind of just believing in
what you've been given.
The most recent song I
wrote, or I'm actually
in the process of writing,
came to me in the dream.
I'm there, and it was actually
Bob Dylan playing what
was more like a hip hop song.
But he's doing it.
I've been at Pearl Jam
rehearsals in my dreams,
and they're playing this
song, and it's really good.
So if you can just remember
it, you were given the song.
It doesn't usually
happen that way,
but there have been
a few of those.
DAVE: I can't leave that
one alone quite yet.
You had a dream about Bob
Dylan singing a hip hop song,
and now you're trying to
recover that and write
that as your song.
ROB HOTCHKISS: And this
one I did, actually,
because I woke up, and you've
got your iPhone these days.
Used to be an old tape
machine or whatever.
But I woke up and I kind of
just did the beat box thing
that I was hearing.
Then I went to the piano
and did the melody,
because this was fully
formed, and then the melody
with the singing.
So that one-- yeah.
DAVE: Do you think
you captured it?
ROB HOTCHKISS: I do, actually.
DAVE: Wow, looking
forward to it.
ROB HOTCHKISS: It will not
sound like a Bob Dylan song,
just so you know.
I don't remember it,
actually, right now.
Yeah, it's on my phone.
Good point.
AUDIENCE: How much
nonmusical infrastructure
is needed to take a song
that's a hit and make it a hit?
Let's say your identical
twin wrote "Drops of Jupiter"
and wasn't in a
band-- what's needed
to get that on the radio?
ROB HOTCHKISS: That
one was interesting.
When we first started
coming up with that,
that was, to me,
like a rock song.
The label president-- it's
weird to have somebody
say something good about
a label president--
but he heard a
string arrangement.
Actually, he had an idea
of who the guy would be.
He said, this is
Paul Buckmaster,
the guy who did the
Elton John arrangements.
He said, he'd be
perfect for this song.
So I had this demo of this
rock song that I got used to.
And I'm sitting at home
and I get in the mail
this version with
the strings on it.
And I was like, you gotta
be kidding me, you know,
what happened to our song?
I actually did prevail in
getting the strings to come
down because they really
beat you over the head
at that point.
But I hated it.
I hated those strings.
So I think maybe
he had that vision.
That song without the
strings, does it still
have the same impact?
Maybe not.
So the arrangement was
important in that one.
Different ways of
going about it.
The Stones are a great
example of a band.
They would sit there and
just kind of-- I mean,
they were talking about
"Exile on Main Street"
where everybody's sleeping.
And Keith and Charlie
are just jamming.
It's 3:00 in the morning
and they're however
drunk they are or whatever.
And Keith would just wait
till he knew he had something.
He would just feel it.
And then you wake everybody up
and you get it at that moment.
So it's part of it.
If you can come up on something
at the moment of creation,
the Stones were
the kings of that.
Those early records-- I mean,
Beatles, Little Richard, you
had to do it.
You didn't have a
bunch of-- you weren't
overdubbing a bunch of stuff.
They went and made a
record in two days.
So if you can capture
the moment of creation,
that's where you
get the real magic.
How does it get on the radio?
These days?
We were talking about that.
These days, I mean, the
labels are basically gone.
They were the filter, you
know, they could tell us,
here are the 20 bands
you should listen to.
Now there's 20,000 bands
that you need to find.
How do you get it on the radio?
I think it's harder
than it's ever been.
Radio seems to have-- there are
20 artists who get all the air
play.
And the rest of us have to
use Google ads or whatever--
you guys know what it is.
DAVE: AdWords.
ROB HOTCHKISS: AdWords.
Yeah.
You got to get creative
and do whatever
it takes to get people
to hear your song.
I wish I had a better answer.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAVE: Is there any
advice you'd give
to a young aspiring
musician or songwriter?
ROB HOTCHKISS: I would say do
it because you have no choice.
Don't want to become one.
Work at Google, be a lawyer.
Do something.
You know, it's hard.
I mean, our son is a musician.
He's actually the
talent in the family.
And he said recently,
he just has do it.
That's why you should do it,
because you just can't not
do it.
DAVE: What are you most
excited for coming up?
ROB HOTCHKISS: Most
We have a show at
Lafayette Town Hall, which
is going to be interesting.
It's with a group called Notes
for Hope cancer awareness
and prevention.
That's in July.
And that's a full band.
So what you saw was
us bringing it to life
with an acoustic
guitar and a box drum.
But full band, drums and
bass, and rock and roll.
That's July 16 in Lafayette
with Notes for Hope.
So excited about that.
We're also going back
to-- we were up by Seattle
on Vashon Island before we
moved here about a year ago.
And they built a
brand-new theater there,
and they're going to
have us come play there.
So if anyone's in the
Pacific Northwest,
July-- that's why
I bring my wife.
July 9, we're going back
home to Vashon Island.
So those are both
exciting shows.
DAVE: Wonderful.
That's so great.
Remember to grab a copy of
Rob's CD on the way out,
and let's hear it one more
time for Rob Hotchkiss.
[APPLAUSE]